okay guys we're back we're back I run
this for us come on and see ya it's a
boy psychobabble the usual and chunk I'm
tired they're sucking it shows okay you
know this is you know what to expect
when come in here a lot of profanity a
lot of slurs our guy you know and it's
not by this time nothing surprises you
from this twisted madman okay all right
let's lucky I was like yeah anything all
right here no no no don't be sorry huh
okay let's look here hi Jessica oh [ __ ]
is this guy dead copy look at this rate
that's what hey Roger no military we've
been the girl make sure the girls walk
bad ok it's about the girl it's gonna be
fine okay let's care love flying bandung
here now i got the rube this let's see
where i'm moving us today yeah I guess
over here
you know guess over here open / all
right before [ __ ] jump down my lesson
nothing so it's safe there we go ooh
whole [ __ ] real fast okay gotta
look for some more hidden items huh as
you know there are like none wait what
is this nothing holy [ __ ] I am I not
funny like any I thought there was like
pen bets chug it
um just so it's out there I can't swim
look it looks like it's shallow on the
right side follow me you can't slam
[ __ ] I'm glad Marlene hire you guys
what do you mean I know you guys are
getting paid for this one I'm trying to
say thanks yeah sure thing hold on guys
let's say yeah let me just um oh [ __ ]
look I'm swimming like little [ __ ]
like lil [ __ ] okay here we go
to [ __ ] sorry I got lucky few is there
for a second
my last mission is pretty easy place is
[ __ ] plotted she can't swim is he
gonna [ __ ] dry line up [ __ ] up what
is she jumped right here that we saw I
saw my change I latex liquid latex like
that no no no no the [ __ ] what happens
now we don't get paid as what happens
you doing tests maybe they uh maybe they
had a map or something to tell us where
they were going how far are we gonna
taste far that needs to go where was
this lab repairs she never said she only
mentioned that it was someplace out west
yeah we're Ellen here this is not us do
you know about us about me I know that
you are smarter than this really guess
what we're shitty people joel has been
that way for a long time we are
survivors since our tail it is over Tess
Jesus now we tried let's just go home
I'm not I'm not going anywhere huh Tess
this is my last stop this is playing the
vaginal card I guess what our luck had
to run out sooner or later you going on
don't don't touch me holy [ __ ] what
she's infected she's not infected I say
Joe let me see I mean what if she shows
a vagina and it just like the leading
built like a natural waiting oh oh oh
oops right
give me your arm this was three weeks I
was bitten an hour ago and it's already
worse this is [ __ ] real Joel you
ain't have to get this girl for tommy's
he used to run with this crew he'll know
where to go no no that was your crew
safe I am NOT doing that yes you are
look there's enough here you have to
feel some sort of obligation to me so
you get her to tommy's ok [ __ ] I thing
back the word
they're here I can buy you some time but
you have you want us to just leave you
here yes there's no way I will not turn
into one of those things I'm exact word
it's easy for me there we gonna fix that
fine no no I'm just go it's [ __ ] okay
I guess she's just gonna quit here le
let that sex is my child I guess he
didn't mean for this get a move on [ __ ]
that was this girl you know I speak here
did she break you are they even caring
idea though
[ __ ] just giving her all supplies I see
the shooting what the [ __ ] I can't
believe we did that stop we just left
her to die stop stay close to me we
happen to them let me take this [ __ ]
they're gonna start shipping over there
we're gonna hear it okay somebody put a
TV in there that's where it go go
upstairs probably get off from there
Thank at just keep pushing for a lot of
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] could we look down over
them I realized she took out two of my
men copy that you take out the goalie me
oh there's the body Tesla's like bloody
over there [ __ ] we gotta get you gone
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] block two dicks
about to get her
[ __ ] we gotta get going [ __ ] us ooh I
will be taking that thank you oh shut i
got this far but peanuts girl [ __ ]
fireflies keep your head down yeah
[ __ ] up by now
okay one more one more for Bambi ouch I
shut the [ __ ] head knows it got oh
[ __ ] there's one right there come on
that's all the ammo
so where to go [ __ ] guys [ __ ] hurt me
[ __ ] him oh really bad with this come on
okay oh [ __ ] well I need the other
[ __ ] god sonakshi doesn't damage
is he dead all right come over his dead
weight meet this guy dropped in the ammo
oh that rifle was good wit they had like
no [ __ ] ammo Jesus oj oj vows oh my
god what have I done what I like that i
kne getting hannah how's that something
she said I could pick it out well full
say with me come on I name her name out
that sad yeah and I got drawer
okay can't get [ __ ] this one's like the
best one better than a [ __ ] rifle
tough [ __ ] now tick god [ __ ] question
we go through that all stay down i don't
know how many more there are no no I
their batch buck
they did say may
oh shet can i grab this guy where's the
other guy okay oh [ __ ]
see okay we got to get the [ __ ] out of
here oh [ __ ] damn it this is [ __ ] up I
don't know I like this oh [ __ ] she had
the mask sooner she's a mean in Africa I
just told you oh hell no you breathed in
mr. some lying to you you [ __ ] liar
tell me that shirt right now feel like I
can tamp out of my throat oh wait you
just search the area let's find them the
hell out of here 40 clicker show up
where is this rat I get this [ __ ] out
I'm still alive I'm still alive and it's
a Hail [ __ ] Jesus well we are really
roughing it that's all I gotta say
I was supposed to grab him but something
went wrong so I guess that's you know
that okay well anyways [ __ ] reload I
guess any [ __ ] pills and headed I'm
not down too hot wait was that a train
station kind of thing at the end the
hell are you just round over here oh
[ __ ] come on Jessica no Jessica
no we didn't come this way so okay guys
we're just [ __ ] doing this [ __ ] was
that I heard a ribbon I hear [ __ ]
danger I heard a ribbit that's all I'm
gonna say hey hey sad here come down oh
I'm like legit in the water okay it's
kind of hard to see with this [ __ ]
smog oh [ __ ] okay
um I don't wanna dive I'm telling like
sure the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] is that okay
I can't like see [ __ ] did oh she's over
there change psych hold on to the rail I
did oh [ __ ] i can see really well now
see that's a lot better underwater than
here darling I'm fine ah this is how she
moving no
okay I get what's this what's this
what still works the ladder
maybe we can use that uh yeah I've been
here for a while now pressing the
triangle I just have to actually get out
I was a lot i right here can she like
climb on us hey betch get over oh yeah
this one early okay I can't see [ __ ] I
gotta shut the [ __ ] up okay I guess she
didn't shave that it now can you get
that ladder place
there you go what's your [ __ ]
district is in the water it's for now
that [ __ ] here here we go ok I got
finally [ __ ] seeing that is
disgusting I'm just checking around real
quick I check around real quick
absolutely nothing good got again and is
that oh it's veritas let's get out of
here what the [ __ ] is that anything over
here ok ok well it looks like we're out
of the sewers I guess so look around
this year thanks for watching guys
seeing the next episode of tanked yeah
Hey look um about Tess I don't even know
there's others things gonna play out you
don't bring up Tess ever likely just
keep our histories to ourselves secondly
don't tell anybody about your condition
they think you're crazy will try to kill
you and lastly you do what I say when I
say it we clear sure repeated what you
say goes yes that a good deal there's a
town a few miles north of here the fella
there that owes me some favors good
chance he could get us a car okay let's
get a move on okay sticks out for
Harambee